[Music]
in South the hate news silences the hey
silence mm smithy by Joe say something
in Japanese go panic so boogers that
actually means boogers Oh
Hana his nose and and so [ __ ] so no [ __ ]
all we say no [ __ ] - Lisa Oh be cool
yeah al Johnson's and dancin several
social media platforms who has a pretty
low stats how alex jones is like a he's
like oh he's the founder of this called
Infowars and they any vocalist saw her
globally literately trying to [ __ ]
put fluoride in our waters to control
our brains basically awesome guys yeah
yeah alright so I'm gonna show you guys
a video and this is this is Joe Rogan's
homie hmm he's been on Joe Rogan before
dog yeah no no that was a really
interesting was a good guys this place
yeah and Trunks told me to and yeah so
his ex-wife the same way she's gonna get
worse probably here we go
Alex Jones America's most notorious
conspiracy theorist responds to being
banned by Apple Facebook YouTube and
Spotify they're hoping you're stupid
they're hoping you believe the fake
narratives about us in the lies they've
said about us now his ex-wife Kelly
Jones is speaking out exclusively to
Inside Edition Victor Topher walking to
know where exactly that he's going to be
so upset and out of control
that it would really become even more
dangerous at meantime Alex Jones is
calling on President Trump to help him
regain his social media platforms we
need to call the White House go Trump's
rallies
Kelly Jones hopes he's yanked
permanently he's engaging in racist in
hateful speech he needs to be held
accountable guys like this get married
you know was married for 12 money baby
what is this ex-wife happy ain't gonna
do it during a heated custody battle so
yeah I don't trust anything about that
yeah you can't toast custody battle
comments it's so hot like I like the
reason why I picture people like that I
feel like how do you have a conversation
with somebody like that you know like in
order to marry them like what if they
get into an argument like how terrible
would that be well that's why she was
getting divorced who she was saying that
he was so like emotionally abusive and
like all that stuff is like he would
just rage whenever they would fight yeah
you look at his voice I bet you his
voice normally without the yelling is
just perfectly fine but he's yells all
the time so it was just right
I like that voice it sounds it sounds a
victory lap yeah something like a
bullfrog yeah it's like nacho Man Randy
Savage
yeah to a slim jim yeah Rob's returning
game okay pretty crazy how this happened
because uh within like a matter of hours
all the companies Facebook Apple Spotify
[ __ ] YouTube they all phantom-like
across the board together What did he
say to get Ben nothing well they just
dude yeah there's a lot of theories
about this [ __ ] I think if anything when
you do this kind of [ __ ] it's called the
Streisand effect where everyone now
starts to listen to them because it's
like what is he saying that's so [ __ ]
crazy the tech bar yes well I don't know
I don't know where cam can get on but
the idea is it's called the Streisand
effect I can't remember exactly what
it's from in telling everyone they can't
listen to somebody it's like a kid it's
like a parent to a kid you can't do this
what do you want to do it and a lot of
people that didn't know who he was in
the past now they're like wait who's
this guy that's so controversial that
everyone has to ban is the number three
most downloaded half now and this has
never happened before where of all these
you know tech social media companies got
together and banned one in division for
a conspiracy guy like Barza cuz he's
he's labeled that like how conspiracy is
it for him to have set for years are all
to trying to shut me down and then they
all do in the action permit that they're
do it they're shutting him down because
they're supporting him so kind of like
the Streisand effect that you're talking
about where they're like we're for this
guy we know
that if we start banning and then
there's gonna get more attention on this
dude I doubt it I doubt it I think I
would love to think that sure I like
that ain't look at Facebook YouTube well
I don't know about Spotify them but
they're clearly left-leaning like
clearly you're oh yeah sale even though
they even know it like all their
employees right and even though Alex
Jones is a conspiracy theory you know
that he's very conservative and
right-leaning so I well he is in a way
but he [ __ ] hated george w bush and
stuff I refer to so he's not really
right not like not in my opinion even
more of like a libertarian guy doesn't
he claimed that he's a conservative I
don't think I don't know I don't know
it's not know enough about it but I feel
like people today they they think what's
all wrong with ignorance get out of it
like do you really want to know that
much like truthful and like corrupt like
things that are going on cuz what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do know it's like in
the matrix like what do you want to be
in the mixture so you want to be like
out of it I want to be doing it but I
think the inner ignorant that people are
afraid of is like when like bad people
start ruling again and everyone's kind
of hopeful I'm talking about more about
people about the Flat Earth it's like so
the earth is flat okay even honey baby
what changes you know what I mean yeah
that's the kind of stuff that throws me
off a little bit you know I mean yeah I
mean you know and okay it's like well he
should be taken off all platforms cuz he
said Sandy hooks hook was a hoax I mean
no no man look
you were just on Sam tripolis thing you
guys talking conspiracy [ __ ] oh yeah
like what if he says a conspiracy that's
not how that's not hip or whatever or
everyone's like you can't shake that
conspiracy like I don't like the whole
like we got to take you down because you
said some crazy speech and all that I
thought you could say as much crazy [ __ ]
as you want as long as you're not
threatening anybody that's a lot of you
are upset about this whole situation
because they're like they're they're
like arboretum of infringing or freedoms
that's [ __ ] up yeah whatever
the thing is he didn't get in trouble
for the conspiracy in Sandy Hook denying
what he got in trouble for was violating
terms and hate speech my mom's against
whatever but but it's very big that's
the issue it's very vague so they could
pick and choose if I don't like you then
I'm gonna take you out well it is a
business though right like if someone's
going into your business and and
disrupting [ __ ] then can't you just a
nice service and it is like Facebook you
know I mean the problem now is like I
feel like a lot of people they don't
understand what freedom of speech means
it's a double-edged sword
you don't I mean so like if you want
this country to have freedom of speech
yeah there's gonna be a lot of like that
[ __ ] to happen but people at the same
time they only want freedom of speech
only when it makes them feel good
freedom of speech doesn't exist to
protect safe speech it exists to protect
controversial speech yes like that's why
they have that yeah exactly not for like
hey everyone agrees with this right like
look at the [ __ ] late-night comedy
right now it's like what everyone agrees
with me TV that's all it is but in it
but you need free speech for the
controversial people who say
controversial people who think that
they're for free speech but they want to
stop free speech at the same time you're
like literally what you're asking for is
not what this country is about you know
what it means so it's kind of weird
where they're like well you shouldn't be
able to say that well they can't say it
but it's strong but at the same time
they have the right to say that that's
what this country yeah and then we also
have the bilious smart people to shut
them down
exactly you know yeah not not consumed
whatever that is right exactly and in
this case they gave them more power by
shutting them down because now him and
his followers are even more like we'll
see of course the [ __ ] big media and
[ __ ] big companies and on top of that
and the right that's what's crazy about
it and I spent a whole day researching
this [ __ ] cuz I was like what the [ __ ]
could he have said that's like right and
it polarizes people because what they
should have done is just let him let him
do his thing but now come at it and
debunk him sure use your freedom of
speech to debunk people that you're
against don't [ __ ] shut them down
completely you just let him win but
nobody wants to debate anymore it's all
like well there's no debate I am right
yeah
when I think they look even more right
cuz I don't even know anything about
them but what like Facebook YouTube and
Spotify is doing it makes it seem like
they're doing like the company version
of like kids I don't want to hear that I
don't talk to me don't talk to me
because there's like even the topic of
like people who want the government to
come in and tell and like cut off what
people can't can't say about certain
things and that's a very for me that's
very dangerous yeah I mean I don't want
any of that you know that's that's
accusing issue that happened in Canada
and I think that's how that professor or
Jordan Jordan Peterson he became very
popular because they were trying to
basically make it a crime to not address
people by their pronoun that they want
to be a drain of considered speech no
beaches this catch-all phrase right I
mean not so if you don't call a
transgender person by their preferred
pronoun like a day or whatever and you
called them him or her then that is
actually hate speech just like saying
the N word to them exactly and he
refused to do that crazy so that became
a huge controversy because he says I
will call people based off of their
preferred pronoun but I will not do it
by law he's like I don't mind calling a
transgender person whatever they prefer
to be called as friends we can do it but
I don't want the government to step in
and say I have to do this or else I'm
gonna get in trouble and it to me it's
no different than bill maher criticizing
Islam which he criticizes every [ __ ]
religion by the way and they go he is
he's a is Lama pho and all the [ __ ] and
it's crazy too because George Carlin
fought back in a day because remember
his uh his bit about the cuss words the
the the the [ __ ] for the words
you can't say on TV right and then he
did that bit in in in a certain state
and he actually went to jail here it yep
so back then it was like you can't say
cuss words because of whatever reason my
on people have to fight for that and you
could use the same argument where it's
like what this venue this is the rules
of this venue but dude it's just a
dangerous precedent it is and remember
that what about that this is no
different than that that asian columnist
hired by the New York Times like I don't
want her to
is your job anymore that I don't know
enough to lose his that's her opinion
she can hate why he wore whatever but
then I don't think she should lose her
job for because she didn't do anything
to violate her and if you don't like it
you don't have to buy the New York on it
and if I don't like Alex Jones I don't
have to listen to Infowars yeah I had a
conversation with somebody too because
they brought this up it's like the terms
of like like racism right they like whoa
wouldn't you want a law where somebody
says that you can't say the word [ __ ]
anymore I'm like no I wouldn't because
that's a very slippery slope yeah
because that you start with that then it
goes into something else you know I mean
you have the right to call me a [ __ ] if
you want but also the right to knock
your [ __ ] ass out but if I had a
friend to put velocity in this fist and
knock you out and see what happens to me
well to me that's like what's gonna
happen when say yeah that word gets bad
but what's gonna happen when they go off
to the funny racial epithets yes then
your mama anymore I like pink you know
you can't see your mama right I do that
cater from time to time like it on that
slippery slope you won't be able to I
think it's considered hate speech when
you can't escape from it and when it's
withholding your your ability to have
the right of happy or like whatever so
so basically it was us there was a case
in a college where in front of the dorm
room of this guy this guy wrote the
Edward like so when he opened up this
door door room he sees it every day
and then he has no choice to escape from
that situation or that semester so
that's considered like a race motivated
live grandma hate crime and a hate
speech so in cases where people cannot
click away or escape from the situation
that is the definition of a hate crime
or or a race yeah and it readjusts on
your rights and your pursuit of being
able to live your life really then it's
considered that right yeah that's like
what people argued about the Confederate
flag where it's like I don't want to
have to see it in a public area again I
have to live in this public area which
isn't just a good argument that's the
way it looks though it's great it's like
trailer impact yeah
the red white blue just rearranged in
different that's very aesthetic right
but you see we're not from the south or
anything like that so I think it doesn't
have that type of hurt yeah where I feel
like maybe you know people that went
through it or their family members they
might see it and get hurt from that I
take because I'm like look you could fly
whatever flag you want just cuz I think
it sucks doesn't mean you can't do that
yeah yeah like but whatever dude that's
that's how it's supposed to work I think
you're supposed to live in a society
where you can be offended by things
yeah because god forbid you live in a
society where you can't where everyone
has to say the same thing at right same
[ __ ] so it's like where do you draw the
line right so if for example the super
neo-nazi groups got really popular and
they started getting some real traction
that was effective in our government and
in people and then it polarized
everybody to the point where a race riot
civil war can happen that could have
been prevented by actually just
controlling the their access to having a
voice or anything like that yeah so so
there there's things like where maybe
government and intervention can prevent
extreme issues from happening
but there's also the other part of like
where do you draw that line I don't know
I think you give more of a voice when
you do that when you try to shut them I
think so so I think there let that buddy
near that talk it's like look at these
freakin crazy asses absolutely give him
the rope to hang himself in and III
enjoy that when I did my on the street
[ __ ] that was always what I did just try
to get people to talk as much as they
can because they they do all the work
for me
so you believe most people are sensible
when they see crazy [ __ ] like that they
go haha that's that's that's ridiculous
I I hope that they are but to me a free
society is about dealing with this kind
of [ __ ]
like having on this kind I can see it
that way then yeah that's the whole
point and we can have to have things
that can offend you around but we all
collectively so I guess the difference
is you know there's two schools of
thought one is let people make decisions
on their own because they're freaking
intelligent they could take care of
themselves the other part is people are
[ __ ] so stupid we need the
government to control them because they
they might be susceptible to whatever
strong person can that can come out and
[ __ ] influence them yeah I mean
everyone's influenced by by things
yeah it just depends on what they're
being influenced by and is it somebody
saying we should break the law because
there's a lot of that going on to where
people are saying you know if if ice is
in your neighborhood fight back and
don't you know like like there's a lot
of and then there's people on the right
who are like you know if I want to have
a gun like if I'm gonna have a a are
like out in public walking around I
should be allowed to but you know we all
have to draw our lines personally where
we do hmm I don't know it's it's not
easy
[Music]